ah well now we're joined as you can see
by the education secretary himself gavin
williamson mr williamson very good
morning to you
good morning a very busy day for for all
of us but not least for for those a
level students receiving their results
today
i wonder if you can put a figure on it
what percentage of grades
have been changed by the standardization
process
from the grades that were awarded by
teachers so uh
if you forgive me but if i can just
start off by congratulating all those
students who will be getting their
grades today and
for all the hard work that they've been
putting in and wishing them well
in their future and as to what they're
going to be going on to next
um but i'm not in a position to be able
to give those figures those will be
released at 9 30 today
as is is usually done but 97
of youngsters who will be receiving
their grades will be getting uh either
the grade that the
school actually gave or within one grade
of what that school gave so that's 97
of those and we are going to be seeing
the number of a's and a stars increase
by 2
this year over last year as well
well the percentage in scotland is
roughly 25
that were changed it does appear that it
is going to be substantially hard
in in england at the very least 40
percent appears to be the figure
the principal of newname sixth form
college said 47
at 301 out of 646 grades
were downgraded another college 55
percent
were downgraded another school 49
of all grades have been downgraded i
mean one head teacher asked me to ask
this question
how is this possible well we've got to
make sure there's proper checks and
balances
within the system and we do recognize
that when ofqual came up with this
system it consulted widely honest it
consulted widely with schools
and colleges as it pulled this system
together
and it is important that if you do not
have checks and balances within the
system you'll have even greater
unfairness where
potentially some people would take
advantage of the fact that there
aren't checks and balances but there are
going to be some students who are in a
situation where they receive a grade
that isn't reflective of their work
and of their efforts over the last few
years and that's why it's been so
important to put in place for triple
lock
make sure that there's systems in place
so that they can have those grades
very quickly and very rapidly looked at
um
and if those grades need to be changed
if they got a valid mock exam
that that can form for the absolute
basis in terms of actually then getting
that grade and there's a whole series uh
of sort of roots of appeal that the
school can take forward
but what you've essentially just said is
that teachers have been taking advantage
of the fact that there are no checks and
balances isn't it
no no no not at all because actually
teachers have worked incredibly hard but
what we
did in terms of creating this system
actually and there's been a wide
understanding because
unlike in scotland we consulted on this
system
we actually published as to how it was
going to work so there's a clear
understanding by teachers
and by schools and colleges as to the
approach that we're taking this was
something that
didn't happen in scotland and we've been
absolutely open and transparent in terms
of how we've
uh how we're going to be doing this and
how we have done this
uh but there is oh sorry i'm sorry you
know
as you say there have been academics and
there have been teachers who have been
contributing to the process and coming
up with this system at the same time
there have been plenty of others who
have been screaming
for months now that we were heading for
precisely this kind of situation
just explain to to the pupils that are
watching this morning in what way
it is fair that an individual's
performance can be accurately
gauged in part by what happened
to the entire year at that school the
previous year
so so what we've done in terms of what
i've called is in terms of actually
pulling together
this system is actually look really
closely at the progression that those
students have actually been making
through that school they've looked very
closely at the
individual assessments of every single
uh teacher that every single teacher has
put in
and and but for the individual for the
individual who has worked their backside
off
for the entire year how is it right that
they can see their grades
that their teacher has given them
downgraded
because of the performance of the year
before
well it is actually on the performance
of what those
children have been doing and the
progress that they have been making
and actually the progress that that
school has been
adding to what those children do but at
the center piece of all of this
is actually the grades and the ranking
order
that the school gives to each of those
children
and so that is at first cornerstone of
actually the awarding of grades by the
exam board and by the assessment and the
invigilation of what of quotas but i'm
i can't sit here and say that every
single child there won't be a single
child in this country
that will be in a situation won't be in
a situation of where they've got a grade
that
isn't a fair reflection of their work
that's why we took the decision in terms
of a triple lock
making sure this incredibly robust
appeals process
so that youngsters are able to go down
that appeals process
and get that um get those issues
addressed and
what we're hearing from what we're also
hearing from you cass just uh
just before i came on is the fact that
actually you know
youngsters when they get their grades
you seem going to be seeing more
youngsters
getting a's and a stars and have done in
previous years
you're going to see young people doing
better than maybe the
previous year's cohort and when they go
to their universities or to their
colleges
they're going to be seeing that the
opportunities are open for them in order
to progress
in order for them to go to university in
order to be able to continue their study
or go into the world of work
can we talk for a second then about
about the appeals process an appeals
process based on on mock exams
again how is that fair given that there
is no
standardized process by which mock exams
are set
and indeed in addition to that many
students in england will not have sat
their mocks
because they're scooped because their
schools went into lockdown how is that
fair
so as you all know the overwhelming
majority of schools
uh across england have actually sort of
sat mock exams uh
usually sort of take place earlier than
when the lockdown would have happened
um and do it in different ways i'm sorry
to keep interrupting minister
debra kidd former teacher academic gives
an example
teacher aide does a short mock to boost
the confidence of her shaky class
teacher b does a full mock and mark them
harshly to give her complacent class a
push
teacher c didn't do mocks with her class
see the problem yet gavin williamson
oh without a shadow of a doubt the best
form of awarding qualifications is
making sure that you have a full exam
series
but we weren't in the situation of
running a full exam series this year
so you have to put in a system that is
both fair it is both robust
but there is an ability for youngsters
to be able to standardize
to marx how is it in fact in addition to
that
often would you mind this morning this
morning off call have not yet got to the
position where they are
able to tell schools what qualifies as a
valid mock
students are getting the results today
and will not know until next week
sometime
whether or not this appeals process is
going to be open to them
so of course are going to be sharing
that information in the early part of
next week we'll be asking schools to be
able to
where they don't think there's been a
fair reflection of pupils work and
efforts to be able to pull that
evidence together and of course will be
turning that round with the exam boards
an incredibly speedy process
to ensure that youngsters if they are in
a position that they need a
better grade and they don't think that
they've got a fair grade as
part of the uh the count as part of the
uh moderated grade system uh that that's
turned round
swiftly uh because universities have
pushed back the date in order for them
to be able to make the final decisions
and those appeals are going to be able
to be heard by the 7th of september
so that they're able to have that
information able to progress onto
university onto college or into the
workplace
why was ofcom not sorry call not in a
position
on results day to be able to tell people
whether or not they might
have an opportunity to appeal on the
basis of their marks why was that not
ready for today
so we were in a position where we made a
decision to give
young people um you know wanted to
enhance the fairness make sure that
hence the options for appeal make sure
that young people
have the best possible options in front
of them
and oftwell are working at great speed
to ensure that this will be out
and with schools um in the next few days
and uh you know i know that the people
at of course work incredibly hard to
ensure that that happens
yeah i asked the question again why was
that not ready for today we're just
hearing the off call of cancel their
press conference for today
so uh the reason the sort of off qual
would have uh
haven't got it ready for today is
because you know is obviously a decision
that was made sort of later on in the
process
and that they're working to make sure
that that information is shared with
schools and colleges
over the next few days but but why i
mean you've known this was coming for
months
people have been warning you of this
situation for months off call
have clearly been bumped into this at
the last minute that's why they're not
doing it
until monday i mean i just don't
understand why
given the fact that you knew these
problems existed with us within the
system
that they were warned about it that you
waited until the scottish
government acted of all things the day
before
a-level results come out it looks
horribly rushed
back of a [ __ ] packet reactionary policy
making on the hoof
well what you've seen is both england
wales and northern ireland
follow the same approach in terms of
taking this approach because we feel
this enhances fairness for students and
i think that's the right thing to do
anything that i can do to make things
more fair for students
give them the best possible options and
make sure that they
get though grades and the results that
they deserve as a result of the work i
think that's the right thing to do
and as education secretary is the right
decision
to make this move and actually give
youngsters
more options and more fairness can you
give
a cast iron guarantee triple locked if
you will
that you will not be forced into the
embarrassing u-turn
that john swinney and nicolas sturgeon
were in scotland that
standardization this uh scheme that you
have been warned about for months
is staying and you're not going to be
doing a u-turn um absolutely
and when we've uh sort of uh consulted
widely and well
went off quark consulted widely in terms
of
uh the uh the sort of the whole system
of awarding
this is the this is the message the
message we got from everyone this is the
right approach to go
forward you've got to have a system that
has checks and balances
that looks at the whole performance and
making sure that you maintain standards
within the exam system
to ensure that that those results carry
credibility